Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2192.
David P Here's a caller who at least seems
to think that he caught me in a double standard.
Let's listen.
This is.
Speaker 2: Interesting.
Something else that I truly don't understand.
All right.
You are in favor of allowing women to decide
what to do with their body.
True abortion.
Have a child.
Etc..
Guilty.
Perfect.
Sounds reasonable to me.
Right.
Good.
Yet, on the other hand.
You criticize.
Perhaps make fun of people who want to dictate
how they want to treat their particular illness
or infectious disease.
You can't have it both ways, Mann explained.
You can.
I'm going to exaggerate and say something
stupid, but on purpose.
If I want to treat COVID or some other illness
or infectious disease with bleach, with cockroach
killer with sawdust.
Okay.
You should let me do it.
Don't criticize.
Speaker 1: There's two different things here.
You should let me do it versus you shouldn't
criticize it.
And I'm sorry, my friend.
There is no double standard here.
Okay.
I have never advocated that it should be illegal
for an individual who's confused.
Right.
To go to the hardware store to buy bleach
or Drano or whatever, and to apply it to the
body interior, extra whatever, because they
think that it will treat COVID.
I have never said it should be illegal.
I have never said when you go and you grab
bleach.
They should ask you, are you going to use
this for covert?
And if you say yes, they call the cops.
I have never said it should be illegal.
What I have said is it's stupid.
What I have said is there's no medical science
that says injecting bleach is good for COVID.
There is no double standard.
I don't think abortion should be against the
law.
It should be up to individuals to decide for
themselves whether that's something they want
to do.
Abortion is an extraordinarily safe medical
procedure.
In most cases.
It's not even a procedure.
It's a it's a medication.
We know all about it.
And it should nobody should be forced to have
an abortion, but it should be available.
People should decide.
Similarly, I am fine with people deciding,
oh, I'm going to I have COVID and I really
don't feel well, I'm having trouble breathing.
I'm going to check myself into the hospital
or I'm going to go and get bleach.
Both should be legal options.
The evidence is that the bleach not only doesn't
work, but it could really hurt you.
And so, again, in going with the medical science,
doctors shouldn't prescribe bleach.
Okay.
There's no double standard here.
But interesting, interesting perspective.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
First Republic Bank has failed and it has
been taken over by Jp morgan Chase.
What is this doing to the economy?
We will discuss.
We're going to talk about weight bias in the
work force, bias against heavy people, overweight
people, obese people.
And it is actually worse for women than men
based on the data we have.
Very interesting story.
We're also going to delve a little bit deeper
into the search for a replacement for Tucker
Carlson.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
Get instant access to the bonus show by signing
up at join Pacman dot com.
Speaker 2: That is a frickin predator right
there.
Speaker 1: The bonus show is not predatory.
It's open and available for you.
If you want it, simply sign up and join time.com.
Otherwise I'll be back to.